okay well thank you
so thank you very much for the
introduction i'm honored to be here i
was trying to think what an open lecture
was and
i decided to go for a very soft star
introduction to hashing and some of you
will
hopefully at least find mightily
entertaining and then i will switch
gears after 10 15 minutes and
then we'll see what happens
but for now just something about hashing
and how you can sort of try to explain
it to people and
so
assume we are trying to distribute some
objects in some boxes we're trying to
make a system for that and we may
think well there's some we certainly
want to make plays for animals so let's
pull all the animals in box one but we
don't know what's coming so how should
we make such a system so the idea is to
use the wheel of fortune right so we
want to place the rabbit we spin the
wheel
it puts it in suggest 10 so we put it
there
continue with the kitten
it suggests four and now we take the
stable
and it goes to two one sorry you have to
wait it's always a little interesting
what happens and you can continue this
way and the nice thing we get out of
just placing things randomly is at least
we don't expect to overfill any boxes so
it's not like it's perfectly placed we
have nothing in two and we have three
and six but there's not a huge crowding
anywhere as it would have been if we had
lots of animals and decided to put them
all in box number one
so for now that's good but really when
we have these systems we want to be able
to find things right we want to know
where do we put wally
and so the way we want to approach this
the simple way is just to spin the wheel
of fortune it says fall and of course
wall is there that's sort of the dream
right
and let's look at a real system instead
of these small systems because you know
i'm interested in real systems so they
take how complicated the real world can
be right so again the challenge is to
find wally
and you just want to spin the wheel of
fortune
and there he is so i needed to do this
because my eyes are not that good
anymore but anyhow that he is so that's
what we want right
so
this is a fully random hash function
i've tried to describe so we want the
recomputable
function that assigns independent random
values to every possible object in the
universe right so you get the rapid gets
one number while it gets another number
and
the nice properties is that because the
numbers were between 1 and 12 the
probability to get the same number as 1
12
and with 18 other objects we expect that
wally gets together with one and a half
other objects
okay so let's put the numbers aside and
so the essential thing here is we want
to be recomputable so if we spin the
wheels again
we want to get the same values
right
and so this is where things become
impossible or not really impossible but
we simply the only way we can do this is
by remembering all the different numbers
but we're trying to design a
system to store things now we just have
to store the numbers as well that just
makes things things far worse
right so what can we do so we want a
recomputable random hash function now no
longer say fully random and so the point
is that on computers things have numbers
they're all only three digit numbers and
now we just pick two of these three
little numbers below a certain prime
and then we create this mathematical
formula based on these two numbers that
tell us where everything goes because we
just have to plug it into the formula
right and the only thing if we just make
sure that the first number is not
different from zero then the probability
that they get the same hash value is 1
12 which is exactly what we're hoping
for
okay so now we know how to create a
storage system we just pick two random
numbers
and now we have our formula we plug
things plug the different things in and
find out where they go
okay so this system has a certain
weakness because we really
would be very concerned if some devil
like that turned up and saw the numbers
that we're dealing with right because if
he saw that then he could figure out
that he should just put in the cow which
is 422
and
then the cow goes up and hides wally and
the whole point was we want to be able
to find wally again right and he can
continue this way and up comes
a bomb and
the whole system blows up right and the
problem here is again that he saw these
random choices and that's sort of the
vulnerability and all these kind of
randomized systems we have we sort of
assume that nobody from outside can see
what's going on inside and that's also
why a lot of security relies on these
kind of secrets in random systems
so
again when we work with these randomized
algorithms we often assume we have these
wonderful fully random hash functions
and the only problem is that they don't
exist but often it suffices with
something more limited that we actually
can guarantee like what we saw before
was low collision probability that with
t different hash values the probability
that two things get the same values one
or t and that's used for storing and
finding objects in computer memory
signatures and many other things
and so the interesting question is what
are kind of probabilistic guarantees are
we actually able to
get with these hash functions since we
can't do the perfect thing and another
very nice one is fair minimize hashing
so that is that given any set of object
each object has basically the same
probability of getting the smallest hash
value and that's used in all kinds of
things in within big data classification
of web pages and all this kind of stuff
and just to show it in action right so
we want to find out who a similar taste
this could be used in recommendation
system
and what we do is just to say well it's
probably the guys who have the same
smallest hash values and at first when
you see this we haven't seen it before
you say well
why right but then you try and you run
an experiment and we see that peter and
lars have the same smallest hash value
and in fact they do have all more films
in common
right
and of course if it was just these small
examples we could do it by hand but you
could do the same thing for books
associate hash values with every word
and see if the two books have the same
smallest hash value and so
mathematically speaking again for any
two sets what we use is the probability
that they get the same smallest hash
value is exactly the size of the
intersection divided by the size of the
union
and but that is only assuming fair
minimize hashing where every element of
the union has exactly the same chance of
getting the smallest hash value
otherwise this equation is not true
right but assuming we have it then we
could just repeat a few with a few of
these fair hash functions to get a good
signature for the book or whatever it is
so we can see if two books have some
similar vocabulary unfortunately bias is
impossible and it's impossible in the
same way as we don't have fully random
hash functions you basically need an
enormous description
but we can get very small bias and
that's one of the things i want to talk
about
but just sort of again as dick mentioned
i
have been doing a lot of this stuff in
the real world and just what happens
with the similarity estimation right so
here is actually i ran this thing with
minwise hashing where i did a number of
different experiments and looked at the
mean and saw how it developed and it
converges beautifully so it looked great
the experiment there's only one detail
that is the truth was down here okay and
that's a kind of problems you have when
you don't use proper hash functions and
this is with real data that's actually
comparing arithmetic sequence against
the random number and just that was
enough to mess up with a simple hash
function like the one we saw before
but again this is good to know because
when you sit there often what you have
is the estimates the real data
disappeared maybe you're trying to find
out why you had an overloaded link
somewhere something like that and you
know the traffic is long gone so you
can't go back and find out you'll just
be working with the wrong information
and then the same
data but with a proper hash function a
proper use of it so it's also better
used which has better convergence it
converges to the right value and the
good thing is and we do it the right way
i can guarantee that things will always
converge to the right value and not some
thing like this thing here
okay
so a short break very short i am going
to switch to latex because i can't
really do math with
this thing here
so
and then he said just
believe
okay
so more so what i'm now going to talk
about is how you can actually achieve
some of this power using tabulation
which is something i've worked on a lot
in recent years here's some of the
papers i'm going to mention things from
but basically the whole point is that
hashing i think is so beautiful you have
these ideas like mine wise hashing and
stuff like that and we've convinced the
rest of the world to use it especially
in big data all kinds of signatures
stuff like that but can we actually
implement these hash functions are there
some simple ones that can actually do
the job for us
so again the target is some simple and
reliable pseudo-random hashing
that provides algorithmically important
probabilistic guarantees similar to
those of truly random hashing so we see
that as a big goal i mean sometimes we
might actually be able to do something
even better but for now i'm just trying
to be as good as fully random
and yet which are easy to implement so
this kind of thing of bridging theory
with the true randomness was something
that can actually be done
and
i think this program is very crucial
because randomized algorithms are very
simple and popular so they're being used
everywhere where right quicksort all
kinds of things people use
so they're out there they're being used
but often people don't do use strong
enough hash functions uh basically since
we don't tell them what to do they ask
their neighbor they may go to dr dobb's
journal and somebody dr jobs journal say
this is a fantastic hash function or
whatever and it's just because it
happened to work for his applications
but maybe his applications weren't that
demanding if he was just using it for
hash tables and stuff like that anything
would do almost anything with do but if
you wanted to use for mine wise hashing
that's a completely different challenge
and we can go on like that right so and
it's really not nice if you wanted to
sign a system for say
what they call it helping flights fly
around to say well this hash function
used in some other context hopefully use
can be used here you need to know when
you can trust systems
and the biggest problem in some sense is
that two simple hash functions may work
deceivingly well in random tests because
everything works in random tests
it's not until you get hit by the wheel
structures of real life that you
discover you have a problem and that may
be too late
so again
hashing just we did it before with
rabbits and kittens and stuff like that
let me now do it more boringly so again
a hash function here is just illustrated
by a funny curly thing it's all out of
control and so when i want to store x in
my hash table when it's chaining i just
go to the hash
to the
list that is pointed out by the hash
function of x and see if it is in that
list and if not i just add it to the
list to the chain then we have the other
classic linear probing where we hash
into an open array we see if x is at
that location if not we go to the next
location next location until we i find x
or find an empty location if we do that
we know x was not in that's where we put
it
we have cocoa hashing where you have two
arrays and we get we have two
independent hash function that gives two
different places and if x is in this
cocoa hashing table then it should be in
one of these two places
okay it's not there so we want to put it
in but now things get complicated but we
can we try to put it in where w was but
w also had two different hash locations
so then we have to see if w can put it
we put in its location it can't but then
we move that and we continue around
until we find an empty place and then we
swap everything around so again google
hashing is great when it's just
searching but the updates are fairly
complicated
all kinds of other applications uh
second moment estimation don't want to
talk about that but i'm going to return
to this minimize hashing we had before
which again is used to decide if two
sets are similar and again the property
we want here is that for any given
element for any element in any set the
probability that it gets the smallest
hash value is one divided by the set
size and then plus minus some bias that
is hopefully really small
and again actually if you use this hash
function i talked about before the
biases of logarithmic size so that's
multiplicative so
the epsilon is not at all not even a
constant it's far beyond that so you
need to be very careful what you do
okay so the classic approach to these
things is khan and wegmans k
independence which says that well we
can't have truly random hashing but
we can have it be k independent which
means that all
keys hash uniformly into the range of
hash values and when we look at k
different keys they hash independently
but only k not everything
and that has this classic implementation
which is just the degree k minus one
polynomial with k random coefficients
and we can sometimes do a little bit
better but it really starts getting slow
i would say when k is bigger than five
or something like that then i don't
really know how to do anything efficient
but it's still a beautiful paradigm
because we can take any application we
have and we can ask
how much independence does it take to
make it work so with chaining we just
saw that we needed independence two
but if we want to have the property that
we don't get more than log n divided by
log log n element in any bucket then we
need that much independence there's some
ways around it but say linear probing
that i talked about which is far more
useful in practice actually needs five
independent hashing so often people just
in practice try to use two independent
hashing but then trouble can happen as
i'll get back to
estimation you need foreign pins and
with min wise independence interesting
thing is that to get
as
sub-constant independent
bias
you need a super constant independence
okay so there's no constant independence
that really suffices here you need to
use these higher independence
so the question is really is this a
right way of attacking things and i
started with mihai
looking at this simple tabulation
hashing that's also called sobrist
hashing that goes back to chess
computers and i'm going to tell about
why it's related to chess computers in a
bit but basically we just take a key and
divide it into characters and i'm
thinking of it as a constant number of
characters to think a 32-bit key is just
being divided into four 8-bit characters
and for each character we have a truly
random hash table mapping all the
characters
and then what we do to compute the hash
of a key is just to look up each
character in its table and xo all the
results so this is super fast if these
tables are small and they are i mean if
you think of 8-bit characters they only
have 256 entries so they fit in the
fastest cache
okay and we just have to do c lookup so
this is very feasible because we're
again dealing with very small tables we
can't
have random hash values for every single
thing in the universe i mean it could be
a size 2 264 that would be way too big
but we can easily have
random store random things for every
single character because they're not too
many of these
okay so
the basic point is that this is actually
just if you look at um
this is three independent this scheme
and it's actually much faster than using
the polynomial method which just needed
a degree two polynomial it's almost
three times as fast it has a speed like
just two regular multiplications
but it's not four independent it's very
easy to see because if you just look at
of keys that consist of two characters
all the combinations of two characters
and two positions and you take the hash
of all of them then they will always get
zero so if you know the hash of three of
them you always know the hash of the
fourth one which also means it's
terrible from a crypto perspective
okay so back to our independence the
cool thing is that even though this is
not even for independent for the pen
that it's not even for independent it
works for all of these things in one
shot so this makes it very easy it's
very easy to implement and all these
applications just work with this thing
here and especially the i mean for
linear probing it's much faster and if
we take these schemes here it would be
you know you would spend a logarithmic
time just computing the hash value and
then you could right as well use a
binary search tree so having this scheme
is much better
so clues actually recommends a scheme
but decides only the three independent
as mathematical quality
so we want to prove that it works which
means that for worse
worst case input so we have to prove
that this dependence cannot come and
hurt us right so we know every time we
have four keys we could have dependents
and yet we have to show that this is not
a problem
here comes a very ugly theorem to look
at
i think some of you are familiar with it
but let me just try to go through it
slowly so i assume i have in balls that
i throw into impins and
that there are
you know they're not much fewer
pins than their balls okay so there
could be fewer
and i do it with simple stipulation and
then i have a special ball the query
ball that i throw somewhere because the
point is when i come with a key i want
to know how many guys did i end up with
okay so we both have a query ball which
is the one we throw that's special and
we ask how many came together with him
and then we count how many other guys it
is that land with him then we have mu
for the expected number which is n
divided by m
and then we get these um error
probability bounds so what's the
probability that we get 1 plus delta mu
to bigger value
and these are the classic channel bounds
you know the only difference between
these and if we had full randomness is
that if we had full randomness we didn't
need the omega and we needed didn't need
the m to the minus gamma so the omega
just means that things happen a bit
slower so we have to go a bit further
out in the uh
a constant factor further out in the
tail to get the same
low probability so the effect is just a
bit slower but it happens but it's only
by constant factor and the other factor
here is basically well if m is large we
could say that this is a very small
probability
right
so this sort of like saying that this
first part here worked with high
probability
that's good
yes what is that in the numerator i
can't my glasses are batteries oh this
gamma here
yeah no the
there in the equation goes to the left
just the e to the delta is that an e or
is that that's e that's just the base of
the natural log
e to the delta so yeah it's just the
classic chain of bounds uh just with two
differences i mean they're important but
only two differences is constant here
and
there's m2 minus
interpolation gamma right that's when i
use simple tribulation to throw the
balls
how do you define if you have emboldens
what's the size of the
small tables
you told us about 32 bits i mean
four characters
yes
so this has nothing to do with the
table so that i'm saying i implement i
throw the balls using simple tabulation
hashing which means i defined at a table
for each character and i use that to
define the hash value and now i just
throw the balls and
and see what they land and see how many
lanes together with a given guy and i'm
claiming we get something very similar
to what we know that if we had full
randomness but if you say only exp used
polynomial hashing or only used k
independence for some constant you would
only have a polynomial tail bound you
wouldn't have this exponential decay
that we like to have and like to think
we have when we have full randomness the
thing we use the statistics and stuff
okay i'm showing how the keysight
corresponds here to the previous
so this has nothing to do with the key
size
this is just if i use this hashing
scheme in this context so all i require
is that the key i only divided into a
constant number of characters
yeah
okay that was okay that was one way okay
so that's the only requirement yes does
that uh gamma depend on the constant or
the yes so the gamma is shoveled in here
yes in the constant so gamma has to be a
constant so for every constant gamma
this is a constant and yes i didn't
write it it's not that bad but i didn't
write it the same constant as the c of
as the c well both c and gamma affects
this constant
but again my experience is actually that
it's best to work with 16 pair
16-bit characters that runs fast on
modern computers and then the constant
is the c is a two so even two to the two
is not so bad so
i mean these are not horrible things so
i mean i'm just claiming that but it
would be horrible to look at if i put it
in
okay but it's
not horrible so
and i'm actually going to prove
something i know that's a normally
advised again but i'm going to give a
simple proof uh i'm just going to show
that if we have hash n keys into n21
plus omega 1 bins then all bins get only
a constant number of bin balls with high
probability
and the reason why this is interesting
is that nothing like that would hold if
we just had k independence for some
constant
okay so we are having uh
we're having polynomial more bins than
we have balls but it could just be 1.1
into 1.1 or something like that
okay so the first part here is our clip
but so the key observation here is that
if we have any set t
of balls then there's of keys then there
is a subset of logarithmic size that
hash completely independently and this
is really one of the key observation
connection with
tabulation hashing and this is very easy
to see because you say let i be a
character position where they defer any
where the keys and t defer and then just
take the least common character on that
position and pick any key that has
a as a character in that position
right and now we throw away all other
keys from t that uses
uh
the character a in position i
okay so now we have
now we have only one key in the system
left that has a in character i and
that's x no one else
okay so the point is that then
the hash of x is independent of
everybody else because it's the only one
that depends on the random hash value
associated with a in position i
okay
and now what we basically do is just to
recurse
on u prime which is just defined
recursively right because we took the
least common
character in that position which means
that we took out at most half the keys
and now we're recursing the rest
okay so this means that we are
guaranteed to have a logarithmic number
of keys pulled out this way and they all
hash completely independently
okay so that was the first claim and the
next one is just that there cannot exist
a
set of whatever number of keys it is
that all hash independence to the same
bin again a very simple argument there
are not that many different sets
and if one of these sets hash
independently
because that's what they should do here
then the probability that they land in
the same bin is very small and then we
just uh do we just multiply the numbers
using a union bound and conclude that
the probability of this bad event that
we had these
keys that hatched independently that
they all landed in the same bin is m2
minus gamma okay so it's just playing
with numbers but
the critical point here is that with
simple separation even though it's only
three independent
but inside any set t which is of super
constant size there's a subset that is
also a super constant size where all the
keys hash independently
okay and then that's really the key and
and you can't get the statement better
than that because if you just think of a
of the keys as being 0 1 vectors then
well then there aren't that many there's
not that much randomness in the system
because when each character position
only use two random hash values so we
can't hope for more independence than
what we're getting this way so this is
really the best argument you could hope
for and this is also
a difference but if you only have very
few characters then again you will get a
large set okay so
in fact
so this thing suffices to i mean when we
had the channel bound that suffices to
show that both
linear probing and
and chaining works very well and in fact
google hashing can also be proved to
work well but that is
a lot more complicated the fundamental
point is that we get obstructions just
by looking at a small number of keys if
you have three keys that hash to the
same two hash values then there's no way
of
resolving things for the sake of cocoa
hashing so you did not have that problem
with things like linear probing and
chaining and stuff like that if you have
a small constant size problem things
will just even out at other places it's
not a big deal but here you need
something far more delicate
so
what i claimed was this is sort of
fast and practical and stuff like that
but i actually ran some experiments
together with yin chang and sort of the
critical thing here is just to say this
is simple tabulation here
right and if you try to compare that
with say the degree five polynomial type
schemes you'll see it's actually
significantly faster so it's about a
factor 10. it's also much much simpler
to implement simple tabulation is i
guess
a couple of lines of code basically
whereas if you want to imply implement
these polynomials you have to implement
long multiplications and all this kind
of stuff which is also why things are
slow this is a
funny way of using tabulation to
implement five independent sort of sort
of like an inbreed between these two
different things but i'm just focused on
this line here you can also see the
difference between this is an old 32-bit
computer and this is a 64-bit computer
the difference are not so big here here
was worse but still this is
significantly faster than using these
polynomials
but what is far more yes
i'm just curious like
what were the topics that
seemed to be faster there oh yeah so i
should also say so these are the cheat
schemes and i'm going to explain why i
call them cheat schemes for now this is
just a universal hashing and two
independent hashing using multiplication
shift methods which is these extremely
fast methods that were pioneered by
diesel wenger where basically this is
the full code
a times x shifts something so basic
instead of doing a times x plus b mod p
you're instead using that you're just
dealing with keys that are powers of two
and then you use that problem language
like c through a way overflow
for free and then your div operation
just becomes a shift and that's why this
kind of stuff is blistering fast it's if
you just want universal low collision
probability you
the multiplier can be from the same
domain as the key
which is for 32-bit keys really fast
whereas for two independents you need to
have the multiplier b from a twice as
big domain 64 bits so well i guess
quadratic domain which you can see gets
much smaller slower here so that's a
64-bit multiplication here that makes a
difference on a 32-bit computer but not
in a 64-bit computer so you can
basically see how they use microcode to
implement the
64-bit super multiplication with several
32-bit multiplications sorry yeah okay i
actually think as i say actually also
like sometimes implementing things as
long as sort of a few lines of codes i
think it's pretty cool to see these kind
of differences
okay
so but what i think is far more
interesting in this thing about what
happens when you use the wrong hash
function so again these were these
functions we talked about when you just
say a times x plus
b
that are these schemes that you see here
where we just do a simple multiplication
so just the most classic hashing and
this is inside linear probing so what it
did was that i took a linear probing
experiment
i did 100 experiments and then i sorted
them by how long time they took
okay so i just did a lot of insertions
and deletions this average time
per insertion of the lesion
right and what you see is that it
actually works extremely well with the
cheat hazing schemes those that do not
have the right properties but sometimes
it goes bad and it gets worse and worse
and worse and actually true average is
logarithmic
so it's not constant as it should be
it's much worse than that
and then you can compare with that with
the scheme for which we have some
guarantees that they work and you could
say even all these hundred experiments
you can hardly see a difference in speed
right these are ordered by how speed and
they're just completely as they should
be so these different schemes here
basically the red one is simple
tabulation and this is five independence
using uh the regular polynomials and the
reason why it's not 10 times faster this
time is that this is in a real
implementation with linear probing where
the bottleneck is actually the indirect
addressing when you look up the first
thing in memory so that's we're adding
up the cost so that's probably most of
the cost and the cost we see from simple
tabulation is just marginal compared
with that
okay
well actually the real cost of the
lookup is probably down here whatever
but so the basic point is just that you
have these simple schemes and hashing
schemes that people often use in
practice and that work terribly so again
multiplicative hashing are used in
practice if it turns out to be very
unreliable and this is actually the
example of typical denial of serverless
attack because it's just based on
consecutive ip addresses and in fact
these arithmetic sequences is exactly
what makes the system break down
and they have excellent performance 95
percent of the time but then they become
systematically terrible
and it really has to do with the way
they place things systematically and
these problems in randomized algorithms
are really hard to detect for
practitioners for them it's hard to know
are we unlucky or is it because there's
a schematic problem and they're not even
reproducible right because as you can
see again if they tried tested the
system to try to see was it why did we
go down we have this denial of service
attack the whole system is in trouble
right and then you test the hash table
and you run it and then most likely you
get one of these nice experiments and 95
experiments where things work perfectly
so conclude no the hash table is fine
but it's not so this is really
absolutely horrible what we're leaving
to the practical world not giving them
proper hash functions and so linear
probing had gotten a reputation for
being fastest in practice but sometimes
it's completely unreliable and indeed at
a t we had all kinds of workarounds like
if there were too many probes we
switched to a different system which
meant we had two systems to maintain and
to debug and all this kind of stuff
so here we actually prove that linear
probing is safe with good probabilistic
performance for all inputs
uh so it is a powerful thing uh that
works for almost everything
but not certainly not everything because
then it would be done and my research
would be ended and stuff like that i
would have to deal with graph problems
or other difficult things
so anyhow
with chaining and linear probing each
operation takes expected constant time
but other square root n operations some
of them are expected to take long time
and if you are a company like a t each
key represent the customer and it's
always the same customers that get into
the large buckets and just telling a
fraction square end of our customers
sorry we don't want to deal with you
because you go in the large buckets it's
just not very acceptable in the real
world
so
but then comes the sort of savior well
if you had truly random hash function
easy to show that within every window of
like login operations the whole thing
takes logarithmic time with high
probability
so if we just had a small buffer which
we actually do in the internet routers
we'd get down to constant time operation
and we can even also hide what goes on
inside the system because we can just
work in this window and we can process a
packet in exactly the same constant time
all the time so from the outside
perspective it would look as if
everything takes exactly the same time
okay so it's also good from a security
perspective
the only problem is that simple
separation doesn't do that i can
construct inputs for which
a logarithmic size window is expected to
take log squared in time
but then comes a twist
so
this is that you i mean the yeah unfolds
you've got patent but pendloy was really
excited why we called it twisted
tabulation but it actually has a a nice
a boring academic explanation so
basically the point is that we take the
first c minus one characters and not
only do we go to get a hash value out of
them we also get an extra twisted
character out of it and what we do with
that is that we take that
twister and
and xor it with the last character
before we look it up so that's the only
difference so instead of just
getting hash values from the first c
minus one characters you get one extra
character
you don't have any extra lookups but you
have a little bit more on your tables
and now everything works perfectly and
just from an implementation perspective
the twisting only results in these two
extra statements in the c code otherwise
everything is exactly the same
c that you would have run if you just
did simple simulation so it's really not
a lot
but it has many other nice applications
so actually these what i said before
with these horrible channel bounds
i claim there's an improvement so the
point is that this plus
it used to be the number of pins to the
minus gamma but if you do something like
throwing coins
then an unbiased coin is just as m equal
to two
and doing m equal to two to the minus
five is not very impressive we don't
want that so instead we can get the
universe to the minus gamma okay so and
that's typically two to the 64 and then
you get whatever gamma you want to the
fifth then you're really talking about a
very small additive probability so
that's an effect of twisting and that's
and and it's really fundamental so the
basic point in it is if you just get
back to this thing is this table will be
fully used as i said before we risk the
sort of worst case for simple tabulation
is that you just have bit strings so you
have these nice big characters 256
characters but you never use more than
zero and one then you use very little
randomness in the system but thanks to
this thing there will be at least one
table where you fully use the randomness
and that's why we start getting a lot
more power
and the same with minimized hashing so
again the minimize hashing was that we
want this fairness that each guy had the
same chance of being smallest
and with simple tribulation we i claimed
we had small bias but it sort of is in
some
and somehow not because if s is the size
of the set we deal with then it's one
divided by s to the 1 over c
that's great if s is large but not if
it's small and again with the twist we
sort of free ourselves for the
combinatorial input that we're dealing
with and instead we get an a bias which
is one or you the universe to one or c
which is then an absolute small bias
instead of this thing that was only
small if we dealt with large sets and
indeed sometimes one deal was small set
so in both cases with the channel bounds
we had the problems that if we just had
two different values like when we throw
coins uh or here when we're dealing with
small sets then we really need the
twisting for things to work out this is
also my student sandalco was part of
doing this
and just to see what happens it makes
things a little bit slower but not by
much
another interesting thing is it works
really well as a pseudorandom number
generator so what happens is when you
want to run these tabulation schemes for
pseudorandom number generator the only
thing that ever changes is the least
character
and if we work with a twisted least
character i can twist any character i
want there's really only one table
you'll need to look up in every time and
that's why the random pseudonumber
generator is twice as fast as the
hashing thing
and it's six times faster than random
from the c library and this is this
standard pseudo rate the number
generator that actually performs really
badly here we're guaranteed that we can
work things with chain of bounds and we
can use them for statistics numerical
integration or anything you want
because you actually do have these chain
of bounds that we use all the time when
we analyze things
so
so we can do a lot with simple
tabulation twisted tabulation but
suppose you really really
you're very traditional person and still
want high independence and there's
actually a few applications of that
still
then
all you have to do is to apply it twice
and again login independence there's
many cases where this is really the only
way we know how to prove that things
work and also with minimize hashing and
china bounce the error that we have
falls exponentially independent so if
you can get a really large independence
you get much better bounds than those we
had before
and so again just recalling what
independence is the standard way of
doing it is just using these polynomials
and it's really a deal when it comes to
space and amount of randomness because
we only have to store k random elements
from the field we're dealing with
but the problem is that we to evaluate
the hash we actually have to look up all
these k coefficients and that takes all
the k time
and this is sort of it's very different
from the tribulation based thing where
we store lots of name randomness but
when we look things up we only look up a
few things
and siegel did some beautiful studies
about that where he showed that
so suppose we want
k independent hashing and want to use
strictly less than k time and and i'm
talking about more computatory i'm only
looking at how many times do you look up
something in memory so i assume that
each memory cell has room for only one
basically what corresponds to one hash
value another question is can we look up
less than k things so we could look up
the k coefficient but is it possible to
look up less
and the answer is negative just
if you're only allowed to do k minus one
probes then your space explodes then you
need u to the one over t space and
that's exactly the kind of space we use
with these tabulation based techniques
and on the positive side he proved that
you can get this kind of u to
omega 1 or c square i know it looks
horrible especially if large constants
are hidden in c to the c time using u 2
1 or c space
so if you want to formulate it as
matching up on lower bounds then you
just say that to get
super constant independence in constant
time you need some
polynomial of the universe space and you
can indeed get that you can get even
a polynomial u independence and constant
time using that space okay so everything
matches nicely
and this is clearly better than the
independent that the log
independence you need for most
applications and if you look at channel
phones and minimize hashing you would
get this kind of bias which is really
small
but as he points out it's far too slow
for any practical application
so
the new thing we had was
that with double subulation you actually
get the same independence but only
spending order c time which is the best
you could hope for that matches this
bound here
and the scheme is very simple and easy
to implement but the analysis is not
and we have done something more
elaborate where we get high independence
but using a little bit longer time
and so this is again using this simple
tabulation which was not only for
independent
but what we claim is that simple
tabulation is expected to yield very
fast unbalanced constant degree
expanders and if we apply twice we get
highly independent hashing and the two
things are very related
so how can i use such a hash function or
any function
as an expander so i just think of a
function that takes my keys and mapping
over to d characters
and i claim that defines a
a natural unbalanced and expanded
because we basically say we get d
different characters and each of them we
we view as just being on the right hand
side in this
bipartite graph so on the one side we
have the universe and on the
right side we have characters together
with their position so output position
characters
okay so again these are the neighbors of
the key x so now we have to find the
graph and we want to claim that this is
an expander
and the cl and the and and that is the
clay case that we proved that with a
reasonable probability if you use 12
times as many output characters as input
characters then we have this property
that if you look at a set that's not too
large then its neighborhood is at least
the half times bigger which is a classic
definition of an expander okay but the
point is that
we don't have any
explicit unparalleled expanders that are
remotely as good i mean those here they
have logarithmic degrees and would be
orders of magnitude slower to compute
so this is a very sort of
we know simple tabulation is extremely
fast so this gives us a very
implementable expander but again it's
not explicit it would be explicit if i
could actually find it doesn't have to
be i'm saying a random simple tabulation
function works there could be an
explicit construction of this tabulation
function i mean an explicit
way of filling out the table that would
make this thing work and then you would
have an extremely efficient explained
expander to use but i don't know how to
do that i think that's a beautiful
problem
so actually what we need to get high
independence is just a weaker notion of
an expander which is that whenever you
look at a set that's not too large
there's some key that has a unique
output character that is not shared by
everybody else right these are the
output characters there's multiple keys
that get to them but this output
character is only
one that x has
and
so you get this kind of unique neighbor
expander if you have if your
neighborhood is bigger than
half times your degree times your size
but you actually get some better bounds
you only need six times as many output
characters as uh input characters to get
these kind of unique expanders and
that's all you need for high
independence
so again we can prove that we get
this unique expander and then siegel has
this idea that's part of his approach
that if you have one of these k unique
functions and you plug them together
with simple stipulation then you get
something that's k independent and
that's very easy to see so what's the
idea
we have first we map our keys into these
output position characters each key gets
d different characters over here and
then we associate with each output
position character a random value and we
just x all these
okay so the point is that x is the only
one who has this output position
character it's the only one that gets
the hash value the random hash value
associated with this output position
character
so again it comes down here so that
means that the hash of x is totally
independent of the hash of the rest of
the set and now we just peel x away and
now we are guaranteed that there's a new
key that has a unique output character
that gives us a hash value that makes
its hash value independent of the rest
okay so it's very simple the connection
between unique expanders unique neighbor
expander and the simple tabulation
so again the corollary is just
if you really want high independence
then all you have to do is to apply a
simple tabulation twice you have to make
sure that in this intermediate domain uh
you use six times as many characters and
that as in your first domain
and again this first unique thing you
only have to guess one of them you don't
need many of them
and so the constants may look horrible
but they're not that bad so i
so not using the formulas because to
make them nice i had to
well hide a lot of constants and stuff
like that but to really compute the
exact constants i found that for 32-bit
keys divided into two characters each
that's two to 16
different characters
we actually do get a 100 unique function
with probability 1 minus 1.5 times 10 to
minus 42. okay so that's pretty small
error probabilities it's probably going
to be the safest part of your hardware
if you just have a usb flash dive with
random bits in your claim here is a
universal k unique simple hash function
that's a very safe claim to make okay
uh
so 100
pendant hashing is thus possible and at
least it's easy to implement
but i still want to say that simple and
twisted tabulation are going to be a lot
faster because you see an intermediate
domain we actually have 20 characters to
look up where we if we just had simple
simulation directly we only had to look
up two things so it is going to be
significantly slower so in the same way
as we normally prefer to use two
independents rather than 20 independence
we also prefer to use simple tabulation
by the same order of magnitude
or
double tabulation and also there's an
issue with space we need far more tables
so the chance that we can stay in cash
is much smaller so that's why i say 10
to 100 times faster and not just 10
times faster so just in lookups it's 10
times faster but including the space is
probably much worse
so open problem on the the k
independence so again we had this
beautiful negative result of sigel the
new positive results are here where
either we sort of sacrifice that the
independence is not as good as it is
down here or
we
down here spend too much time with this
is the optimal thing relative to
seagulls bounds and what we really what
i really would like to see was if it's
possible to get u to omega one over c
independence in the optimal time using
optimal space
and
for that i know i still believe that
double tabulation is doing that directly
i just don't know how to prove it
but let's go even further what if you
really don't want any notion of anything
you just want fully random hashing
okay so that's of course a deal thing so
it turns out that we can't do that by
any given set as using with high
probability uh using only linear space
and that was already proved by pay and
pay but we now get a really simple
version of it we use double tabulation
again so the requirement is just that
the size of the set you look at is well
it actually just has to be
uh 0.9 times five but let me just say
the size of the alphabet divided by two
right so the randomness in the system is
the size of the alphabet so if you want
full randomness you clearly can't deal
with a set that's bigger than that but
if you deal with a set that's just half
of that
or less then with high probability you
get full randomness on the set so for
many applications you just have to be
lucky that you get this full randomness
and then you can just forget everything
about restrictions
so just to compare with the
theorem we had before some some very
nice things happen
here right because before when we want
high independence we needed six times as
many characters output characters as
input characters here we need four
independent how many input characters
there were so this gives a much more
efficient scheme okay so even if you
have 20 input characters you still only
need two four characters in output
and the other difference is again that
here we had what we had here was
independence which says that for
every single set
subset of the universe that had less
characters than this the list keys than
that we had full independence this
statement is very different it's for
much larger sets
but on the other hand it's only with
high probability for that given set
and i just want to say the previous
photo random hashing actually uses this
thing as a subroutine which means it had
to deal with these six times more
characters and stuff like that so
now we just see that we get this fully
random hashing directly with double
tabulation without having to go through
this construction here okay so at least
now fully random hashing if you're
willing to spend as much space as the
size of the set you can get it with high
probability with a trivial algorithm
okay so this should be very useful in
algorithmic design
and also just to
i know i'm almost out of time but i want
to i claimed something abstract i wanted
to take away but then i thought okay
i'll try to put it back i'm going i need
one more slide okay so what's really
going on here again is the same
uniqueness as before what we show is
that if you have this hash function
which is random simple simulation and if
you're dealing with a set which is less
than half the alphabet size then with
this low probability here or with this
high probability
uh every subset of the set has a unique
output character okay so again it's
pretty much the same statement as we had
before where you can use peeling and
again we now have that the probability
of things go wrong is phi to the d half
rounded down and that's how i got the d
equal to 4 here because then it's a
well two here
okay
um
i think i made a little mistake but it's
basically a thing so
how do i one of the things that claimed
the abstract was that we had two large
sets we had a simple way of this if
they're very similar we have a simple
way of finding out exactly what the
difference is
so i'm just looking at weighted sets
that i think of as a vector over set u
where the support that is the number of
non-zero elements are s so that's
different way of talking about a
weighted set but it's more easy when we
want to talk about
vectors and stuff like that and i want
the linear sketch of the set which has
only order in size so that if is smaller
than that i can recover s directly from
this linear sketch so this is these
invertible bloom filters of galbraith
and bismarck i think they're extremely
cute
and what's the application of this that
is that if you're given two the linear
sketch of two sets and if the difference
is small then you can recover the
difference just by subtracting the
linear sketch of one from the other
okay so we have this similarity
estimation before which is about telling
about how similar are things how much of
the different and stuff like that if
things are really similar then we can
even tell exactly what the difference is
you have these huge sets you just get
this little bit of information from each
of it then you combine it and now you
can just say exactly what are the
elements in which to defer the other
example if you have all these people who
enter
a cinema and they try to run out and you
want to see if anybody is left and you
just have this little sketch that you
could track on and then you can say oh
carl and peter still here just by
looking at that little bit of
information even though thousands of
people came in and left
it was not a reference to paris or
anything like that
so
i just want to so to make this work all
you really need is just to make sure
that the keys are identifiable so you
add some signature of some kind so you
can easily given an element from sort of
an even bigger universe see if it's a
possible key
and then you use this random symbol
stipulation from before and you can see
the picture looks very much like the
proof with seagulls peeling but now what
you do is every single key you add its
name to all its neighbors
so x had a unique name so when i added
its names all its neighbors and i did
that for every key it still only says x
here so i can still see it says x
with other ones this complete garbage
was there because i added up all kinds
of keys but there's one there's i'm
guaranteed that there's one key i can
just look at and see here it is
then i can pull him out from the scratch
and now i'm again guarantee that there's
a key that's alone and hence where i can
see what's going on i pull it out oh
yeah well i
didn't have time to write more slides
but the basic point is just i can
completely recover them just because
there will always be some information
that's not garbage where i can see what
element is pull him out and continue
okay so this is sort of the formal way
of doing the same thing
okay
so as you can see i've had a lot of fun
with this kind of tabulation because it
actually seems like a lot of these
things we like to do with hashing is
possible using this tabulation
and i say it almost much as the power of
that idealistic fully random hashing and
we even get that with high probability
and and it's really uh simple to use and
and it's blistering fast
it contrasts classic polynomial hashing
where we can have lots of randomness
because we can have lots of randomness
in the tables but the whole point is
that only little is used in each hash
computation that's a general idea why
you have tables in general you don't
want to
do all the computation it takes a lot of
computation to put into the tables but
at first it's there when you want to
compute a new value you don't have to
look make too many lookups
and one of the nice thing is that for
these tables we only need a pointer to
some randomly configured memory without
any special structure so this could just
be really cheap fast read only memory
you don't even need to change it or
anything like that so somebody just
gives you a bunch of random bits in a
space and you can just use it you just
need a pointer to them that's it
and that's also really good for
multi-core systems and stuff like that
because when we do read only it leaves
the cache clean everybody can work on it
in parallel it's very easy so you can
imagine some huge tables which would
mean that even 32-bit characters may be
very easy to
support
okay and then we are talking about maybe
two logos or something like that and
then it gets even faster
and you can also do limited randomness
because you can really just think of it
as pre-processing steps so if you your
application is something that only log
needs log n independence and if
tabulation works then it also works if
you just use log n independence
pseudorandom number generator to fill in
the tables okay so it's not like that i
was tabulation say you need more
randomness than you needed before it's
just the space that gets into account
gets used right i i use it to precompute
the tables and now everything is fast
so again there's a generic open problem
that says that because it's so fast and
easy to implement
you should just take anything you do
with hashing and then this might
actually be a way of making it really
happen in the sense that you may be able
to prove that tabulation works it's
often
it's the proofs can be fairly
complicated at least that's my
experience at least for me they can be
fairly complicated
but it's worth it in the sense that well
for two reasons right so one thing is
instead of trying to do a new hash
function to every single application you
have in mind and then tell people what
it is if we can just prove the same hash
function uses all these different things
and it's kind of also proving some more
general power right because you really
expect it to just be points and really
the hash function is working for the
convex hall of all these points right
you know it works here you know it works
here it probably also works all kind of
places in the middle right so it's much
more appealing than having a different
hash function for every single
application so that's one big advantage
for this program it's really you just
tell people yeah simple separation works
for that as well right so instead of
this thing with the guy from dr dobbs
that says i really like this hash
function seems to work here we actually
can sort of make proofs that works for
other applications
uh
and also and and just sort of in that
line recently with uh my students
at least some of them i showed that
simple tabulation gives the power of
choices load balancing some of you may
know what it is some of you are not but
the basic thing is we had these things
with uh throwing balls into bins and we
got up to log and divided by log log n
in one of the bins but you can get down
to log log just using a power of choice
where every time you want to throw a bin
a ball you get two bins to choose from
and you put it in the smaller so that
thing works almost perfectly with a
simple tabulation there's a minor
difference you only get the same
expected bound as a worst case but then
you get it within a constant factor
anyhow just to say there are all kinds
of places where it seems to be useful
and one of my
uh the problems i really like here is
that we're really close to match
sequence bound i would like to
understand this whole i mean i first
ditched high independence but i somehow
still like it anyway and i would really
like to know is it possible to get u to
the one over c independence in order c
time using u2 one or c space
right so and i think we are getting very
close i can get it within a log factor
in the time and i think it's time to
close that problem
uh and the while conjecture is a double
tablation achieves this
okay i just don't want my favorite tool
to be used to doing it but it's okay if
you can do it no ways
okay so that's really it
time
so it seems that double having the
vocabulary is the way to go
uh yeah but that was 20 10 to 100 times
more expensive so i would much rather
use simple tabulation if i can
yeah well yeah if you just want the full
randomness with high probabilities and
that's also then it's a very good way to
go but
if you want this thing with
many lookups it's a little too
thank
expensive